do you want to play battlefield ones DLC
maps with your friends but don't have
the $50 to spend on a premium pass yeah
me too
well developer dice is introducing a new
feature which lets you play on a DLC map
with a group of friends as long as one
of them owns it but of course there's
always a catch
I'm Matt and this GameSpot news update
is available to anyone with the Internet
Premium friends does let you play
battlefield ones DLC maps as long as
you're playing with a friend that owns
them but unfortunately there's a major
caveat you'll only get experience for
the matches played on the maps you own
that means if you're playing on a DLC
map you don't own that experience will
be banked and you'll be able to receive
it by buying the add-on content on top
of that you won't be able to use any of
the expansions weapons or vehicles until
you purchase the DLC Premium friends is
set for a test run during the upcoming
battle fest event which begins on March
30th battlefield ones first expansion
they shall not pass recently debuted for
all players but we still don't have
release dates for the next three make
sure to hit that like and subscribe
button to be the first to learn when
each expansion arrives and if you want
more intense action-packed warfare then
check out our video on the five guns we
love from Mass Effect Andromeda
[Music]